what are the five ways that you list
that are the roots of war
yeah so i mean they're kind of like
buckets like there's sort of things that
rhyme
right in the interval you know because
it's not all the same there's like lots
of reasons to go to where there's this
great line
you know there's a reason for every war
and a war for every reason
and that's true and it's kind of
overwhelming right and and it's
overwhelming for a lot of people it was
overwhelming for me for a lot of time
and i think i think one of the gifts of
this of social sciences actually people
have started to organize this for us and
i just tried to organize it like a tiny
bit better buckets that rhyme buckets
yeah some economics before right
metaphors so so the idea was that like
that basic instead of like something
overrides these incentives and and i
guess i was saying there's five ways
there that they get overrided and three
are i'd call strategic like they're kind
of logical there's circumstances
that um and and this is they're sort of
where strategic is the strategy is like
the the game theory is you could use
those two things interchangeably but but
game theory is sort of making it sound
more complicated i think than it is it's
basically saying that there's times when
this is like
the optimal choice because of
circumstances and and and one of them is
when
the people who are deciding don't bear
those costs so
that's or or maybe even have a private
incentive that's gonna that's that's uh
if they don't if they're ignoring the
cost then maybe the costs of war are not
so material uh that's a contributing
factor another is just there's
uncertainty and we can talk about that
but there's just the absence of
information means that actually there's
circumstances where it's your best
choice to
attack there's this thing that political
economists call commitment problems
which are basically saying there's some
big power shift that you can avoid by
attacking now so it's like a dynamic
incentive it's sort of saying well in
order to keep something from happening
in the future
i can attack now and because of the
structure of incentives it actually
makes sense for me even the words in
theory
uh really costly or it is really costing
nonetheless
and then there's these sort of human
things
one's a little bit like just war one
sort of thing there's like ideologies or
principles or things we value
that weigh against those costs
like
exterminating the heretical idea
or standing up for a principle
might be so valuable to me that i'm
willing to
use violence even if it's costly
and there's nothing irrational about
that
and then
the fifth bucket is is all of the
irrationalities all the passions and all
of the most importantly i think like
misperceptions the way we get like we
basically make wrong calculations about
whether or not war is the right decision
we get our we miss we misunderstand or
misjudge our enemy or misjudge ourselves
so if you put all those things into
buckets so how much can it be modeled
in in a in a simple game theoretic way
and how much of it is a giant human mess
so four of those five are really
on some level easy to
think strategically and model in a
simple way
um
in the sense that any of us can do it
right we do this all the time you know
think of like bargaining
in a market for
a carpet or something or whatever you're
bargained for
you're thinking a few steps ahead about
what your opponent's going to do
and you stake out a hyper like a low
price and and the seller stakes out a
high price
and you might both say oh i refuse to
like i could never accept that and
there's all this sort of cheap talk
um but you kind of understand where
you're going and it's efficient to like
find a deal and buy the market by the
carpet eventually um so we all
understand this like game theory in the
strategy i think intuitively
or maybe even a closer example is like
suppose
i don't know you have a tenant you need
to evict or any one normal like kind of
legal or not it's not yet a legal
dispute right like we just have a
dispute with a neighbor or somebody else
most of us don't end up going to court
going to court is like the war option
that's the costly thing that we just
ought to be able to avoid we ought to be
able to find something between ourselves
that doesn't you know require this
hiring lawyers and a long drawn out
trial and most of the time we do
right and so so we all understand that
incentives and then
for those five buckets
so everything except all the irrational
and the misperceptions are really easy
to model then from a technical
standpoint it's actually pretty tricky
to model
the misperceptions and i'm not a game
theorist uh and so i'm more channeling
my colleagues who do this and and what i
know
um but but it's not rocket science i
mean i think that's what i that's kind
of what i try to lay out in the book is
like there's this all this all these
ideas out there that that can actually
help us just make sense of all these
wars
um and and just some bring some order to
the
more ass of real reasons well to push
back
a lot of things in one sentence so first
of all rocket science is actually pretty
simple
people i think i'll i'll defer to you
actually well i think it's because
unfortunately it's very like engineering
it's very well defined the problem is
well defined the problem with humanity
is that it's actually complicated so it
is true it's not rocket science but it
is not true it's easy because it's not
rocket science but
the
the the problem the the downside of of
game theory
is not that it helps us make sense of
the world
it projects a simple model of the world
that brings us comfort in thinking we
understand yeah and sometimes that
simplification
is actually getting at the core
first principles on
understanding of something and sometimes
it fools us into thinking we understand
so for example i mean
mutually assured destruction is a very
simple model and people argue all the
time whether that's actually a good
model or not but you know there's
empirical fact that we're still alive as
a human civilization and also mo in the
game theoretic sense do we model
individual leaders
and their relationships
do we um the staff the generals
uh or do we also
um have to model the culture the people
the
the the suffering of the people the
economic frustration or the anger the
distrust
you have to model all those things do
they come into play
and sometimes i mean again we could be
romanticizing
those things from a historical
perspective but when you look at history
and you look at the way wars start
it sometimes feels
like a little bit of a misunderstanding
escalates
escalates escalates
and
just builds on top of itself and all of
a sudden it's an all-out war
um it's the escalation with nobody
hitting the brakes so
so i mean you're absolutely right like
in the sense that it's totally possible
to oversimplify these things and take
the game theory too seriously and and
some
and and and people who
study those things and write those
models and
people like me who use them sometimes
make that mistake i think that's not the
mistake that most people make most often
and it's actually true i think most
people we're actually really quick
whether it's the the u.s invasion of
afghanistan or iraq we're really quick
to blame that on
the humanness and the culture and that
so we're really quick to say oh this was
george w bush's
either desire for revenge and vengeance
or some private agenda or blood for oil
um so we're really quick to blame it on
these things and then we're really we
tend to overlook the strategic
incentives
to
to attack which i think we're probably
dominant i think those things might have
been true to a degree but i don't think
they were enough to ever you know bring
those wars about just like i think
people are very quick to sort of in this
current invasion to sort of
talk about
putin's
um grand
visions of being the next catherine the
great or
or or nationalist ideals or
and and the mistakes and the
miscalculations are really quick to sort
of say oh that that must be and then
kind of pause and or not positive maybe
even stop there and not see some of the
strategic
incentives and so
so i i guess we have to do both um but
the strategic i guess i would say like
the
war is just such a big problem it's just
so costly
that the strategic
incentives and and the things that game
theory has given us are like really
important in understanding why there was
so little room for negotiation in a
bargain that things like a leader's
mistakes start to matter or leaders
nationalist ideals or delusions or
vengeance actually matters because those
do matter but they only matter when the
capacity to find a deal is so
narrow because of the circumstances and
so let's not
let's it's sort of like saying um like
an elderly person who dies of pneumonia
right pneumonia killed them
obviously but that's not the reason
pneumonia was able to kill them all of
the fundamentals and the circumstances
were like made them very fragile and
that's how i think all the strategic
forces
make that situation fragile
and then the miscalculations and the all
these things you just said which are so
important are kind of like the pneumonia
and let's sort of let's pay attention to
both
and you're saying that people don't
disproportionately pay attention to the
it's hard i mean it wasn't to the
leaders it took me a long time to learn
to recognize them and it takes many
people you know it took and it took
generations of social scientists
um years and years to figure
figure some of this out and to sort of
help people understand it and clarify
concepts so it's not it's just not that
easy now it's not hard i think it's
possible to just as i was taught a lot
of the stuff i write in the book in
graduate school or from reading and like
it's possible to communicate and learn
this stuff but it's still really hard
and so so so
that's kind of what i was trying to do
was like close that gap and just make it
help people recognize
these things in the wild
you